there's a lot to discuss and unpack here
joining me now to do just that
is stephen miller former white house
senior advisor to president trump and
k.t mcfarland former deputy national
secretary uh security adviser i should
say for the trump administration and
author of the book revolution
so thank you both very much obviously a
great deal going on here when we're
dealing with the the world scene but it
matters to every single american because
our loved ones are in the military we
know that things that happen far away
affect us immediately and can hear at
home uh stephen let me start with you uh
you heard the monologue what is your
take on the crises now multiple that
continue to unfold worldwide
this is an extremely dangerous
crisis moment for america because the
whole world knows what we all know here
in the united states which is that joe
biden is not mentally or physically fit
to be president that nobody has any
confidence whatsoever in the vice
president and that the speaker of the
house the third in line is a lame duck
so you have a country
without leadership now that doesn't mean
there's no policy you have radical
leftists and marxists and communists
throughout the government setting policy
but those who have decision-making
authority in this government are not
capable of executing their jobs that
invites
bad malicious actors all around the
world to go on the march and that is
what we are tragically seeing right now
now both of you of course have been in
the room you've seen the conversations
you you've dealt with all kinds of
people around the world you know how a
president with resolve and strength and
vision
deals with these monsters and they are
monsters around the world kt what's your
take on even as as biden and putin talk
it almost seems like it makes things
more dangerous for them to get
confirmation that this guy doesn't know
what he's doing
yeah i mean there's it's a central
tenant of foreign policy that if your
adversary is weak at home
that's your time to move that's when you
want to exploit the situation so where
where are we today well we have high
inflation high unemployment stagnant
economy a president who can't get his
agenda passed who's in clear cognitive
decline and as you point out a vice
president who's even worse
and at the same time we see a russia who
seems to be ascendant and while the
united states gave up energy
independence that was the single biggest
thing
administration gave it up and so what
does he do at the same time allows
russia to have the whip hand over all of
europe right russia currently gives 35
of the energy to germany with the north
stream too they'll give a far higher
percentage do you really think germany
is going to step up and quit and in the
middle of the winter
risk having a lot of course in germans
well and support ukraine now also and
stephen i mean this is we're also as a
result helping to fund russia because
the main income framework there is their
oil right it's it's that and and germany
sees an america and a joe biden that
abandoned afghanistan abandoned allies
as though they're going to rely on him
if they in fact say you know they're
going to cut the pipeline everyone you
saw it with taiwan started talking about
well we now have to figure out how to do
this alone is this a world that is going
to make those kinds of decisions stephen
as a world alone that america in fact is
considered gone
well you see you see a world in chaos i
mean just a short time after biden was
inaugurated you saw the middle east in
flames you saw attacks on israel because
dangerous violent unstable parts of the
world
sees an opportunity with the weakness we
see in our country right now do a simple
thought experiment if you gave china
russia and other global adversaries
challengers and competitors all around
the world the chance to hobble and
[ __ ] america
what would they do differently than joe
biden they would do the exact same thing
they would inflate the dollar they would
make us energy reliant on foreign
countries they would open up our borders
they would let crime plague our cities
they would pay our people not to work
and they would have a supply chain
crisis so we couldn't supply our country
he's literally putting in place the
policies our adversaries and enemies
would wish upon us kt i'm going to give
you the last word here this is a
remarkable time americans we know in
whole do not like what's happening what
do you imagine the next year being like
with all of this unfolding what do you
predict
we're the most dangerous time we've been
in 50 years i was in the reagan
administration and saw him turn the
world around turn the united states
around and the world around what i'm
very concerned with is that russia is
going to make a move against ukraine
this winter and the united states will
issue strong statements but nothing will
happen and it'll be a one-two punch that
china will come next with taiwan and
then you've got nato the stability or
the lack thereof of nato after something
like this obviously china and taiwan and
on this anniversary of pearl harbor day
it's a reminder about what other
countries are capable of doing uh when
you're not looking thank you both very
much i appreciate it now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else